charges between a man and a woman and
states must respect that I'm gay
people I'm Dave Rubin this is the Reuben
report it is April 17
2023 I hope that you had a great weekend
we had a storm hit Miami last night from
about 3 A.M to 4 AM that was the
craziest electric lightning storm I've
ever seen in my entire life we had a dog
going bananas we had babies crying cats
and dogs it was nuts
some a little fatigue this morning but I
have caffeinated and I am ready to roll
we got a tremendous program for you and
we have a post game wrap up over at
reubenreport.locals.com exclusively for
paid subscribers if you want to join us
over there and the theme today is that
it is time whether you like it or not to
usher in a new political ERA this this
binary that we've been working off of
this left verse right Democrat versus
Republican thing it's not working it's
not working we all know it's not working
it's making everybody crazy and we
actually have a chance right now for
many reasons partly related to the
internet partly related to Old
institutions dying we actually have a
chance to usher in something much better
something that will be in line with uh I
think what you are if I dare call you a
freedom lover uh and there's a bunch of
those decent liberal types who are
starting to wake up to it and I think
they could be key piece in how we get to
the other side of all of this stuff and
frankly I've had enough of letting the
crazy people run the Asylum it's time
the same people took over so that's what
we're going to be talking about today
before we do let me talk to you guys
about Mike box real quick you guys know
that 60 of U.S pork production comes
from one company owned by the Chinese
and their Hogs are given something
called ractopamine which is banned at
160 countries including China yet you
find it in your grocery aisle every day
well there's a better way guys let me
tell you about moink that is Moo plus
oink moink delivers grass-fed and
grass-finished beef and lamb pastured
pork and chicken and sustainable wild
caught Alaskan salmon straight to your
door you choose the meat delivered in
every box like rib eyes to chicken
breasts to pork chops to salmon fillets
and much more plus you can cancel
anytime there's nothing better than
cooking their meats on my big green egg
on a Friday evening which I did on a
Saturday evening this weekend Shark Tank
host Kevin O'Leary called moink's bacon
the best bacon he's ever tasted and they
guarantee you'll say oink oink I'm just
so happy I got Mike keep American
farming going by signing up at
moinkbox.com Reuben right now and you'll
get free filet mignon in every order for
a year that's one of the best filet
mignon you'll ever taste but only for a
limited time mlink box.com
rubenmortinkbox.com Reuben and now back
to me okay so let's dive right into it
uh you've heard of this fella Bill Maher
I talk about him uh quite often on this
show and the main reason as you know
that I do
is because I think he represents
something that's sort of bigger than
Bill Maher the man himself Bill Maher
the man himself may never get to the
other side I'm going to keep working on
him I really will he may never get there
but the people that he's talking to the
somewhat sane non-woke Libs who are
factory setting Democrats but who have
started to wake up to the woke stuff who
are realizing that places like Florida
are not places to fear but actually are
the places that are Defending Your
purported liberal values I think those
are the people that we can actually
convince I have no doubt that some of
you are those very people and on his
show every week something happens that
strengthens uh that argument so uh
congresswoman Katie Porter from
California she's a progressive Lefty
from California she was one of the
guests on the panel over the weekend she
was on there with Piers Morgan of course
you guys know who Pierce Morgan is and
they got into the debate about trans
athletes and should biological males be
competing with biological females and
peers and I generally like peers
sometimes I don't but he's you know kind
of basically okay at this point watch
him just dissect her or fillet her like
a fish
you should be able to have a civil
debate nobody including Riley Gaines who
I disagree with strongly should be
disagree with out of interest
um I I think that it should be up to
sporting bodies to make the decisions
about who she said that's actually wrong
I think that what she has done is try to
turn this we talked about people you
know becoming using things to kind of
get likes and get clicks that's not what
she's doing I'm not I've got no truck
right against personally but all I've
seen to do is stand up for women's
rights to fairness and equality she has
she actually competed against Leah
Thomas and it was obviously unfair Leah
Thomas won one of the races in the NCAA
championships by 50 seconds against a
bunch of biological females who simply
couldn't keep up that cannot be right it
cannot be fair that is something
that I trust I think our sporting bodies
should be dealing with and by the way
Riley is speaking up for herself
and that is her prerogative and I
respect her free speech I think she's
speaking after pretty much every female
athlete in the world
isn't it so interesting I always tell
you guys how progressives there's this
thin veneer of Tolerance and diversity
but right beneath that you usually find
an authoritarian but the other thing you
might find is just someone who doesn't
know what they're talking about and
that's exactly what Katie Porter is
Right Pierce is just saying the basic
truth and we all know it's the basic
truth we get caught in this argument all
the time but biological men generally
speaking are stronger and bigger and
more athletic than biological women and
that's why this whole thing has burst
forth because we are watching male
wrestlers beat the crap out of women we
are watching male swimmers Crush every
female swimming record and it's the
feminists the supposed people who are
for women who are defending it it is
completely insane peers because he's
just telling the truth is fairly calm as
he's saying it and you can see she's
sort of just is slowly admitting through
her gibberish that she doesn't know what
she's saying it should be left up to the
sporting but bodies oh so if the
sporting bodies decided to get rid of
the trans swimmers you'd be for that
well what kind of position is that is
that a principled position like what
actually are you saying and that Riley
Gaines Riley gains the incredible female
swimmer uh who again lost to Leah Thomas
by 50 seconds although it was here in
Florida and Ron DeSantis actually made
sure that she got the the gold uh that
she's just doing this for clicks and
likes she's put her her life into this
she's a young woman who's put everything
she has into becoming the best swimmer
she could possibly be is basically at
the Apex of that as a female swimmer and
is getting crushed by a guy with a penis
Leah Thomas has a penis and as Connor
has often noted it is possible that he
is using the penis to his Advantage
during swimming because it acts as a
propeller we haven't checked the science
on that but Connor said it I'm just
repeating it okay so that was the Conor
Theory that's what we're going to call
that for now on anyway Porter doesn't
know what she's saying Piers just you
know fillets her nice and easily and
here's Bill Maher jumping in and once
again Bill Maher taking the same liberal
position which is completely at odds
with the insane Progressive position
wasn't that wasn't that the point of
Title IX Title Nine in the early 70s was
something that was a it was a major
event in feminism that we finally have
this law that says at colleges right and
I think high schools do but definitely
colleges women women sports have to be
given equal to men's sports so that
women aren't you know and this led to
the WNBA and lots of other stuff this
seems to be the opposite of that it
seems to be so many instances I think
where wokeness is the opposite of what I
grew up as the lyrics
liberalism was let's give the women an
equal shot let me put a bail in the in
the swimming pool with the women I don't
get it it's crazy and meanwhile trans
people who genuinely want to compete at
Athletics and swimming or whatever it
may be they're the ones who are
suffering here they need to be found a
way to compete fairly and justly what's
your answer then I think there's one or
two answers I think they either compete
against their biological sex as many of
them did before or you create an
entirely new category or transgender
and then they're able to compete fairly
but what you cannot do is continue to
allow more and more trans athletes to
start decimating women's records in some
cases irrevocably it's just not fair
okay it's just so great before I address
bill I mean peers really did a great job
here he thought this through they you
know they give you the topics before you
do a show like that and it seems fairly
obvious to me that Katie Porter because
she did what a progressive does they
think they can just go on these shows
and say things and the implication is if
you're against me you're somehow a bigot
or a Transformer saying so that no one
will ever push back but again he calmly
when she says well what would you do
okay well there's two things we can do
what are those two things trans people
can have their own separate League
against trans people so be it and if I
don't know how many people will be in
that league but okay or you go against
the people of your biological sex
congratulations and then as he's saying
calmly what we all know to be true you
can see she's kind of like this but she
has nothing to say so now as far as bill
now Bill once again yes you are right
Bill woke has nothing to do with
liberalism but the party that you
support the Democrat Party is the party
that is ushering in wokeness and
destroying your very precious liberalism
I'll send you another copy of my first
book you might enjoy it so the question
is how is it that two liberals Bill
Maher
and Piers Morgan how is it that they are
diametrically opposed to this Democrat
she represents what the Democrat Party
is give me a Democrat a mainstream
Democrat who would argue the sanity that
Bill Maher and Piers Morgan are arguing
arguing there there are none there are
none the the mainstream Democrat Party
positions have completely alienated
Common Sense rationality reality and and
the decent American citizen but how does
that happen well as you know politics is
Downstream from culture so what has
culture been doing to us uh well here's
a tweet from outkick I don't watch
Saturday Night Live so I did see this on
the Twitter instead of Comedy SNL
Embraces full-blown activism a
non-binary cast member appeared on
Weekend Update last night to advocate
for gender transitions for minors well
ladles and jelly spoons we've got video
of the purported comedy show Saturday
Night Live uh doing just that
I was going to say Enjoy but I don't see
how you're going to be able to
since we started this year over 400
anti-lgbtq bills have been introduced
across the country many of which
directly Target trans youth here to talk
about it is someone with their own
introduction
member it's Molly
[Applause]
made it thank you Mr Che Molly what is
all this well as you know I've been
wanting to come to update and talk about
trans people but I have for a much
longer time than that wanted to fly down
from the ceiling listen to that Michael
yeah restricting health care for kids
for some reason there's something about
the word trans that makes people forget
the word kids if you don't care about
trans kids lives it means you don't care
about freaking kids lives wow
you know at one point I heard a crew guy
say is she gonna die up there and then
another guy was like you mean are they
going to die up there
and then they both walked away and
didn't help
which feels a lot like how trans people
are being treated right now
hey Mr J am I still in the frame I mean
your feet are off
[Applause]
NPC non-playable character that's what
everyone in that audience applauding
they don't even know what they're
applauding there's nothing funny about
it by the way this woman she's a woman I
don't care if she identifies as
non-binary I'm not even sure what that
means and she can go about her life
living however she wishes but everyone
watching that knows she's a chick right
she's a chick
she's a low-grade Melissa McCarthy
that's all but she is a woman so if she
identifies as a man and a woman that
okay go do that but why are you pushing
this stuff on kids once again of course
the host there he uh intros the segment
intros her by saying that there are more
than 400 anti-lgbt bills I mean there's
just no such thing there are bills that
are trying to protect youth from having
their genitals chopped off which is
something that we all would have agreed
on 10 years ago by the way at this point
I think it's fair to say that if you are
a pro-trans when it comes to kids
meaning you are for them going on
hormone blockers and having their
breasts cut off and all the rest of it
you're actually anti-gay so it's not
anti-lgbt because a certain set of these
kids will just turn out to be gay kids
meaning it is a young girl
who's probably a tomboy and maybe would
grow up maybe is the key part would grow
up just to be a lesbian an old-fashioned
rugby playing Ellen DeGeneres style
lesbian or it might be an effeminate gay
boy who might grow up to be hopefully a
functional adult gay man and you are the
ones that are that are literally abusing
them literally
but this is what they do they push so
they lie about the intro there are four
it makes the average person watching
like oh my god there are 400 at the LGBT
bills listen I live in Florida I live in
Florida everything is just fine here
actually we did have one incident this
weekend I don't know if you saw it I put
it on Twitter but uh we heard a crash in
the backyard this is a little sidebar we
heard a crash in the backyard as we were
in the pool yesterday and uh an iguana
fell out of a tree did you guys see this
Clyde got into a huge fight with the
Iguana blood flying all over the place
anyway I separate them the Iguana ends
up chilling out in the pool I think the
saltwater might have healed him up
stayed in there for about an hour Clyde
was freaking out it all worked out the
point is that's the worst of what's
going on here in Florida okay that was a
hell of a Segway uh everything else is
fine they're not coming for gay people
or anything else and these people are
just liars and frauds and that girl is a
girl you call yourself whatever you want
you're still a chick okay
she also looks like Katie Porter which
is hilarious he was really making the
rounds this weekend anyway so what do
you do because
mainstream Democrat culture is
alienating all of the Liberals it's not
just if you're watching this and you're
more conservative and more libertarian
or whatever you're going okay surprise
surprise but then there's that same set
of people that somewhat sane said to
people but they're just late to the
party and we gotta welcome them to party
sure we've been partying we've been
having a great time everybody's nice and
toasty but we still we want to go home
you know what I mean we've had enough
but then they come to the door and
they're they just were at a really
shitty party and they would like to
party with us and we have to be
welcoming so that they can come to our
party if we have to go out and get more
tequila or whatever they like we'll go
out and do it that's what we're trying
to do around here but it never stops
with these people check out this
headline from the televised mental
institution known as MSNBC this weekend
Ron DeSantis is desperation for Powers
destroying an entire State and they use
the black and white image which makes it
real scary because that gives it like
the the Hitler Hue right just absolute
nonsense uh redhead libertarian over
there on Twitter uh she said she
retweeted it and said Governor DeSantis
you can't sex change for your kids sorry
you can't
wait you can't sex change for your child
in Florida she worded that a little
strangely and then of course she
retweeted the MSNBC article Elon Musk
saw that and he wrote any parent or
Doctor Who sterilizes a child before
they are a consenting adult should go to
prison for life which by the way is the
law that they just passed here in
Florida and again you must understand to
bring my theory together Elon Musk is an
old school liberal remember that
classical liberal thing I was screaming
about for a long time so now you've got
Piers Morgan you've got Bill Maher
you've got Elon Musk I think we can
throw Joe Rogan into that bucket you
have all of these people and what are
they what is happening to them they are
being alienated by the Democrat Party
they are being alienated by the failure
of liberals to defend liberalism and you
might remember this because it's
translating into something that I think
could really affect the 2024 election
this is a couple months back random
Twitter account tweeted at Elon would
you support Ron DeSantis in 2024 Elon
Elon yes okay well now we've got
something a lifelong Democrat who as you
guys may remember
has only voted for a republican once it
was since he moved down to Texas and he
voted voted for Myra Flores who was the
congresswoman in one of the Border towns
so and by the way he also moved because
he wanted lower taxes in Texas not only
for himself but for Tesla and several
other of his companies I have a feeling
he's going to get Twitter out of San
Francisco he bought that after he moved
so the issue here is why are these
people waking up and partly I think we
actually have to thank the progressives
their hysteria related to the inability
to understand basic biology and and
basic facts and reality
related to this trans stuff and related
to a whole bunch more but the trans
stuff is like just so freaking obvious
it's just handing us it's handing us a
gift and we have to take that gift and
you know what you do with that gift you
take that gift and then you just say the
freaking truth and a whole bunch of
people will come around I believe this I
fundamentally believe this here's
Governor Ron DeSantis this weekend he
was at Liberty University Liberty
University of course is the largest
Evangelical college in the United States
they do something on Sundays called
Sunday convocation in front of 14
000 students it's a massive massive
event I did it about a year or two ago
no no I guess it was before covet man
the world the world's going fast so I
did it a couple years ago it's just an
absolutely incredible event uh here is
DeSantis this past weekend at Liberty
University uh talking about how out of
control this trans situation is
it is wrong to have a swimmer compete
for three years on the men's swim team
switched to the women's team and then
win the Women's National Championship
that is a fraud that is wrong
okay now you really need to understand
if we could bring this back to the top
for just a second do you think Ron
DeSantis is doing it for clicks and
likes do you think what those kids are
applauding for are clicks and likes or
just basically telling the truth
the simple truth
girls and boys are different
I'm pretty sure you know the answer to
that but DeSantis obviously is making
the rounds and it is very very clear to
me uh Donald Trump had a couple more
sort of insane over-the-top attacks on
him this weekend that DeSantis is the
front runner he is obviously the front
runner because everybody whether it is
MSNBC with ridiculous articles like that
or Donald Trump on Truth social with his
own ridiculous attacks claiming that Ron
DeSantis basically as Karl Rove working
for him for a campaign first off there
is no campaign yet it would be illegal
if there was a campaign uh and uh Donald
Trump did hire Carl Rove in 2020 but
putting all of that aside everybody's
sort of attacking DeSantis and that kind
of tells you who is over the target at
the moment uh here he has given a speech
a couple of this was either Saturday I
think this was on Saturday uh and
dealing with some woke protesters who
yeah well you know how they are
if you looked at Governor races
president races 2010 12 14 16 18. yeah
thank you
um
[Applause]
you gotta have a little Spice in the
speech right I mean you got to have a
little fun
why you'd want to pay the ticket to get
in just to do that I don't know but
Different Strokes for different folks
yeah calmly coolly dealing with it as
for Jews against the santis like what
planet Are You On You Crazy this
is Florida you know how many Jews are in
Florida that used to be a joke that
there's a lot of Jews in Florida and
guess what all the Jews are still coming
down here and most of the Jews get it
and are fighting from freedom fighting
for Freedom this is the promised land
sister
by the way the reason she was protesting
was because Rhonda said this will be I
think he's doing a one day event in
Israel in Jerusalem at the end of the
month it's actually the day that I get
to Israel so I'm landing at like 7 A.M
we're going to book it to Jerusalem so I
can hopefully be there for that I'll ask
him how he feels about the Jews but I'm
pretty sure he's cool with the morons uh
but it's not just the right positions
right it's not just the right positions
that he's taking that you watching this
are taking it's that you can actually
then show people if you take the right
positions success starts to flourish so
check this out this is from John Solomon
Florida finishes first for economic
performance over the past decade with a
link to justthenews.com and I got to
read some of this to you because it's
really just on point when they tell you
how evil and scary and mean Florida is
the annual Rich States poor states
report from the American legislative
exchange Council shows the Sunshine
State
outperforming all yeah all
other states economically over the past
decade and for net immigration thanks to
the state's low tax burdens and worker
friendly policies the Alec report is
based on economic data collected over
the past 10 years and performance
rankings are worked out by three
variables absolute domestic migration
State gross domestic product and
non-farm payroll employment Florida was
tops for economic performance over the
past decade followed by Utah Arizona
Idaho and Colorado and was ninth for
overall economic Outlook overall Florida
is tops in the U.S for domestic
migration fifth for State gross domestic
product and fourth for non-farm payroll
employment since Governor DeSantis took
over in 2019 Florida has seen a huge
amount of growth over the past decade
economic growth has grown from an
average of four percent to six percent
to almost 14 percent in 2021 despite
taking a heavy dip to nearly zero in
2020 due to 19 pandemic shutdowns the
economic Outlook is influenced by 15
State policy variables states that have
lower taxes and that spend less on
welfare and Universal basic income
programs tend to have a higher growth
rate than states with higher tax burdens
who spend more this is the eighth year
to row that Florida has made the top 10
in the report for economic Outlook and
net migration and business growth the
state will likely continue on that Trend
as the data shows that over 1.6 million
people move to Florida between 2012 and
2021 New York was the worst in the
rankings preceded by Vermont Minnesota
New Jersey and Illinois do you get it
guys if you have a vision and your
vision is connected to reality and you
put that Vision into action good things
start to happen not only do good people
start coming to your state but the
people who live there
start living those ideas and then they
have more money in their pocket and they
start spending more money and they bring
more businesses and then they start
going for their dreams and that's what
life is all about okay so it should not
surprise you that the states with low
taxes and without all these crazy
government programs and the rest of it
are the ones that are flourishing
economically and then people want to
come there and you know where they don't
want to go they don't want to go to Cali
New York Illinois Jersey etc etc uh Team
DeSantis on Twitter put this up I
thought it laid it out quite nicely
dear Democrat Governors not that your
boss in the white house has finally
admitted covet is over we wanted to send
an update on the new Florida residents
who fled your disastrous policy since
the pandemic began without your
lockdowns vaccine mandates and
devastating school closures our new
residents have been greatly enjoying the
restored freedoms we know you also enjoy
the taste of Florida's freedom on your
own lockdown getaway here but unlike you
your former residents are staying for
good perhaps the millions of illegal
migrants you're encouraging to come
across the border can find a new home in
your alleged Sanctuary
we're happy to fly them your way team
DeSantis
and it's good man you don't need over
the top name calling you don't need BS
lines of attack and the rest of it what
you need are the obvious truths and that
is why everyone's attacking the Sanders
again I don't you know what I say this
to you guys all the time but I hope you
really understand it when I'm when I'm
doing all this stuff about what's going
on in Florida and what governor DeSantis
has done here yes at some level it is it
is personal to me because I live here
and I moved two companies here and all
my employees are here and now I have
family moving down here and everything
else so that is true but it really is
because I know that obviously most of
you do not live in Florida but wherever
you live whether you live literally live
in Texas where it's going pretty well or
you live in Cali where it's you know
pretty crappy I want you to understand
that there are simple ways to make it
better there really are and the think
about it the end there is what is the
best part of it it's like oh all of the
good people the productive people will
move here you know who will move into
your States you Sanctuary people all of
the illegals and congratulate Nations
they will come with crime and drugs and
everything else so it's not just guys
that mainstream Democrats alienate sane
liberals like Elon Musk and Bill Maher
of course they do that they also amplify
DeSantis desantis's success and
Florida's success I should say because
they show because that in essence
showcases the failures So speaking of
failures let's talk about New York City
what's going on in New York City well
you guys know every day we could show
you the crazy crime and there's another
story of someone being pushed into a
Subway or an assault on Asian people but
we're not allowed to talk about not
because it's usually a person of a
certain skin color and we don't want to
be called racist but mayor Eric Adams
and Eric Adams once again was brought on
to be a same liberal right he was not
the crazy nut bag Socialist Communist
lunatic Bill de Blasio people said he
would be sane it was very obvious to me
that wasn't going to be the case uh he
was on Don lemon's show over here on CNN
uh and listen to this doozy
do you have a view on why San Francisco
has this reputation or even in in places
like Chicago or Philadelphia or here how
concerned are you about this perception
that cities like New York are dangerous
well we should be clear that New York
City is the the safest big city in
America and that is often a loss when
you see a dangerous act highlight uh
that's one of the issues yeah no okay
first off let's do uh lemon you see the
way he sugarcoats the question are you
concerned about the reputation not the
reality are you concerned about the
reputation and then he says are you
concerned about the perception so it's
about reputation and perception rather
than the reality that we all know is
happening in New York City then he comes
in and says well okay Eric Adams comes
in and says okay well we're the we're
the safest big city now first off
there's just simply no way that that's
true why are all the cops fleeing why
does nobody feel safe in New York City
like everyone knows it everyone knows it
and I'll give you some numbers on that
in just a second but it's also all you
would have to do is just think okay well
how was New York City five years ago how
was New York City 10 years ago 15 years
ago and it was flourishing and it simply
is not flourishing anymore but we'll
give you some numbers on it this is from
The New York Times which I'm told is a
very reputable paper by the lefties
Major Crimes Rose 22 percent in New York
City even as shootings fell homicides
fell last year to their lowest level
since 2019 before the pandemic but other
categories of crime including robbery
and burglary drove the overall increase
compared with 21. surges in robbery
burglary and other crimes drove a 22
percent increase in overall major crimes
in New York City last year compared with
the year prior despite a significant
drop in shootings and murders the
declines in murders and shootings last
year appeared to be in line with similar
drops in other U.S cities which like New
York experienced a surge in such crimes
in 2020 and 2021 amid the worst of the
pandemic criminal justice experts said
these experts cautioned against reading
too much into the data for a single year
so you get the point there during covid
when we were supposed to be locked in
our houses except we could go outside to
Riot and you know do something about
George Floyd murders were going bananas
so they slightly went down in New York
for 2021 because we weren't rampaging
through the streets thank you thank you
and so these numbers are a little screwy
but the point is everyone knows who in
their right mind find someone please
somebody find somebody and I'll put them
on the show I'm taking my family to New
York City for all the opportunity we're
gonna buy a nice apartment in New York
City and I'm going to open up a brick
and mortar mom and Bob shop
that person does not exist why does that
person not exist because this dingbat
Eric Adams decided to defund the police
and go after the police and you're not
going to be arrested for jumping the
turnstile you guys know the Litany of
things and it's not just happening in
New York City it's happening in La San
Francisco et cetera et cetera uh we
thought we'd show you a little a couple
of videos here of things that are going
on in some of these wonderfully uh run
Democrat cities here's uh Los Angeles
over the weekend uh here's a bunch of
people attacking a gas station because I
guess getting Slim Jims over at Target
is a little too much for them
into our Newsroom show room shows
hundreds of people crowding in ARCO near
Central and
Aloft are smashing the door dozens of
looters flooded into the store grabbing
anything they could La sheriff's
deputies tell us there were thousands of
dollars worth of merchandise stolen and
a thousand more in Damages this as
deputies deal with numerous Street
takeovers throughout the city deputies
say they couldn't intervene because of
safety concerns as they were very
outnumbered only one arrest
the guy taking the condoms did you see
that at the end he's just grabbing all
the real take the ribs I'll take the
lambskin I'll take the black one give me
the condoms as if anyone's having sex
with that guy like what are they doing
you're breaking just everything being
equal if you're one of these looters
what are you doing why are you breaking
into a gas station literally let me get
Doritos and sugar-free Red Bull
go to Target like you usually do you
might you might walk out of there with
the television what are you doing at a
gas station really think I'd like a
keychain
some windshield wiper fluid
you go to Target they have everything
they got kids toys you can get the
newest transformer you get a basketball
[Music]
idiots all right so that's Los Angeles
why a mob would be guys you want to
break into a gas station it just sounds
so idiotic but here's Chicago and now
Chicago plenty of people got killed this
weekend but we're just going to show you
a general chaos and remember they have a
new mayor this is not Lori Lightfoot but
they got someone even more radically
left than Lori Lightfoot which shows you
that uh you know there really is no end
to this thing here's just general chaos
of Chicago
[Applause]
oh
thank you
[Music]
are you on citizen or no I am
can you imagine being the one cop who
just drove down the street in the middle
of that thing like I was just looking
for a donut shop I'm not here to stop
you
I mean it's just utter Mayhem it looks
like the Reuben family Thanksgiving out
there I mean it's just chaos but this is
what they want and they will just get
more of it you must understand they will
just get more of it uh by the way
Walmart announced that they are closing
one of their main stores in Chicago over
the weekend and there were protests
against Walmart so Walmart was like you
know we've just about had it with all
the criminal looting and the stealing of
all the stuff and nothing safe here and
we can't get people to work for us we've
got to go
they protest saying Walmart's racist and
they don't want to be around and then
they burn down the city these people are
out of control guys so what do you do
how about I give you a couple
suggestions I got five of them for you
today you know what one thing you could
do is you could strengthen the culture
and the family within your own Community
every single one of us can do this do
you remember this video this is back in
2015 during the Freddie gray riots now I
know we have riots every uh so often
sometimes For No Good Reason like in
Chicago but this is a spectacular moment
from Baltimore during the riots when one
mother got out there and she just laid
it out on her son for being a lawless
hooligan take a look
captivated by a Baltimore mother reading
the wrong
to remove him from the riot
I don't know her name is Toya Graham and
she's a single mom of five girls and a
boy
there you go Toya so that's one thing
you could do right you could try to
parent a little bit better you could try
to be involved in your kids lives a
little bit more so they're not eager to
say tear down a statue that they know
nothing about or burn down a city or
take all of the
keep thinking slim jim what else do they
have in gas stations these days you're
getting your slim jim your sugar-free
Red Bull your keychains give me one more
good thing you'd get only at a gas
station
what Juicy Fruit gum okay you can only
get it at gas stations apparently so
that's one thing you could do you could
be involved in your kid's life you know
what another thing you could do number
two here you could pursue and expose the
truth that's something you could do
that's something we try to do over here
and tonight uh by the way Elon Musk will
be on Tucker Carlson they've released
some previews of that and uh he started
talking about what it is like to pursue
and expose the truth
the degree to which various government
agencies had effectively had full access
to everything that was going on on
Twitter blew my mind I was not aware of
that would that include people's DMs
uh yes
okay so obviously a lot more is going to
come out of this for those of you that
are not on Twitter you may not know the
DM is the direct message that's supposed
to be private right so if I follow
somebody and they follow me I can
communicate them you can message them
back and forth in essence like sending a
private email to somebody we are now
finding out it's not just that they were
Shadow Banning people it's not that they
were suspending people and blowing up
accounts and all of that stuff and and
all the Litany of other things that
we're still finding out there's probably
way more that we don't know and
everything else we're also finding out
that they could read your private
messages which should not come as a
surprise to anybody because as you may
remember during the height of the hunter
Biden laptop Fiasco they disabled your
ability to even share the link to the
New York Post story within your private
DMS so pursue and expose the truth good
on you Elon Musk you know what you do
after that you follow through on your
political convictions we showed you this
one before but it's worth bearing
mention once again would you support Ron
DeSantis in 2020 for Elon yes so you do
it you go ahead and do it you don't just
say I'm gonna pursue the truth when you
find somebody else that's trying to do
something roughly saying you get on
board the train number four you know
what else you can do you can call out
and convince those who don't uh get it
right the people that are out there that
are still confused about the issues you
can do your best to engage with them
you've seen this one once or twice but
that's what I did with Bill Maher
if California yeah says I have to take
shots
and DeSantis says I don't
hello Florida
that's what I'll say about DeSantis
he's a good dude he's a good dude
he really is and he doesn't care whether
you smoke weed and he doesn't care who
you marry just he doesn't but to sound
like the uh
voiceover and a movie that's coming out
soon
just got real
but like for me personally really
just got real with that yeah and that's
that's in my mind I left this place
because of it and I don't want to leave
the leave this place that it would be
very hard I'm 66 years old I I know I
look 40. look amazing the hair seems
thicker than it was years a couple years
ago I don't know what your dinner
it was not but it's not easy for anyone
right the point is you sit down with
people who are starting to get it and
you start encouraging them to really get
down to the end of the road or at least
as the road forks go that way a little
bit let's see what happens over there
but it's not just those on the left we
should be talking to and having to call
out when people on the right
have made serious mistakes and then are
are uh I would say unfairly attacking
people for things that they themselves
have done you should call out that too
and I know this is going to get a lot of
the trolls and Bots pissed at me but uh
here's president Trump making a whole
bunch of mistakes
but there are many states out there that
are looking at this and they're
reviewing it and they're saying
we shouldn't be even included in this
you know there are some that want to
open up almost now now if we disagree
with it we're not going to let them open
we're not going to let them open if some
Governor said you know has a lot of
problems a lot of cases a lot of death
and they want to open early we're not
going to let it happen okay so I'm not
doing that to be an over the attack over
the top attack on Trump but the point is
he made mistakes along the way too and
all of us that can accept it some
mistakes can be made and people vote the
wrong way and all of that we have to put
this on the side and go straight through
and you go straight through with a
little bravery and a little honesty and
a little righteous indignation you know
what number five is don't bend the knee
for political correctness if 15 years
ago and this stuff was really bubbling
up or even 10 years ago when this stuff
was bubbling up if more of us had just
said no no no no no no something really
bad is happening here now there were a
whole bunch of us there really were I
mean it's what put me on the map is what
put Jordan Peterson on the map it's what
put Ben Shapiro on the map there was a
whole bunch of us going this political
correctness thing something something
ain't right and I'm not saying we all
started there were people that were
doing it before us but if more of us had
really thought about what this could rot
on society what this could on Earth I
think we could have stopped a lot of
that so do not give in to this
politically correct monster your your
silence is what feeds the Beast here's
comedian Steve Harvey talking to Jerry
Seinfeld about political incorrectness
the problem with any joke is no matter
what joke I tell it could offend someone
right I've been in the club one night
and I was doing a joke about a dude
driving drunk the whole room laughing
lady came up to me after the show was
over crying her eyes out yeah I came in
here to have a good time I lost my child
to a drunk driver right and here you are
bringing it up again how insensitive can
you be right well damn I didn't know you
was here
probably still would have did it yeah
because sometimes you have to sacrifice
one for the many the rest of us like you
say need the humor to get through our
day
so find some humor in all of this stuff
it's what I'm trying to do here every
day it'll keep you sane and then the
more that they go crazy and if you think
it's weird now that they want to chop
kids genitals off God only knows what
these people will be trying for in five
years but they will not stop but another
another path is being forged right now
you really can feel it guys I'm not for
progressing for the sake of progress
right that's what progressives are for
but we are at a really interesting Fork
right now the old world the old media
structure the old way of politics all of
that stuff is dying and there's a new
set of people whether they're
technologists like Elon Musk whether
they're politicians like Rhonda santis
whether there's maybe maybe they're
media people like me whether they're
trying to usher in the new world and
we've all got to get on board that thing
it doesn't mean we have to agree on
everything as a matter of fact the
beauty of that thing is you don't have
to agree on everything but trust me guys
if we get on board that thing we can get
through this thing that's where I'm at I
suspect and hope you are with me ladies
and gentlemen It Is MeMe Monday over at
the Reuben report locals Community
here's the one I put up Democrats in
2020 make everyone stay home Democrats
in 21 make everyone get the jab
Democrats in 22. everyone has to watch
drag queens and everyone has to watch
drag queens twerk in front of kids
Democrats in 23 why won't conservatives
just give up their guns you get it so a
whole bunch of you guys are putting your
memes in there I'll be checking them out
throughout the day if you have not
subscribed yet at rumble.com our Rumble
numbers are blowing up guys we're
building the future of the internet as I
mentioned last week Rumble will be the
exclusive live streamer of all the
Republican debates first one is in
August so I'll be at all the debates
it's going to be a blast and yes sorry
not sorry YouTube we're getting all of
them and if you want to join us for the
post game show in about 32 seconds join
us right now at reubenreport.locals.com
we leave you with a Democrat with a fake
accent and I'll see everybody else in
just a bit
I don't feel no Ways Tired
[Applause]
from where I started from nobody told me
that the road would be easy
I don't believe he brought me this far
to leave me
[Music]